everyone has secrets if not their own in
someone else's
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you how did you end up like
this
are you gonna kill me people actually
ask you it comes up
what was done to you might help you what
if a see it makes me worse
I've already killed survived
[Music]
if you say with great power comes great
responsibility
go later in the day later in the day
your impressions are very funny with
great power comes great spider-man
references so what a surprise that right
after doing a spider-man trailer Marvel
drops another trailer with a notable
spider-man reference the absolute
biggest spider-man reference you could
probably make so let's break this down
and if you are finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be a whole
bunch of Marvel happening between this
black panther all the spider-man stuff
that just dropped earlier today so
there's another new giveaway at the end
of the video but just to start with the
biggest stuff that's not in this trailer
you've probably seen the set photos of
David Tennant with her shooting scenes
meaning that we're gonna see killgrave
comeback albeit as mindspace killgrave
because he's still dead it's not like
he's been resurrected it's just that her
trauma is manifesting itself as a
hallucination so it's him speaking to
her and her just reliving a lot of that
but then they also find creative ways to
weave that into her real life while
she's walking around she's investigating
this office here she rips the cover off
of this painting and it's a picture of
her done in the art style of the classic
comic book so he's implication here is
that she'll be seeing some of the
aftermath of kilgrave this is probably
something that he had made like he was
obsessed with her he made all those
photo collages so he probably
commissioned a bunch of paintings and
she's just finding some of that stuff
now so just prepare for her to be
triggered but then there's a lot of
funny scenes of her throwing people
around in bars just being classic
Jessica Jones obviously this is all
happening after defenders so she's
gotten a little bit better but it's not
like all those experiences completely
fixed her she's still living with the
daily trauma of everything she went
through with kilgrave so the actual
antagonist of season 2 is supposed to be
a group of people that is tied to the
place that gave both of them powers
killgrave and jessica jones so remember
the lab that gave them experiments we
started to learn a little bit about them
during season 1 but they just sort of
left that as a hanging plot thread that
continues on you
see her looking at those medical reports
then Patsy Walker Hellcat is talking to
her like hey maybe revisiting some of
the things that happened to you will
help you deal with this new problem that
you have so it sounds like the new
problem is tied to the place that gave
her powers so that'll be a bit of a
change they did say that they were going
a little off comic book so don't expect
any specific comic book storyline but
obviously all the season one characters
that survived season one will come back
so you have Malcolm you have Patsy
Walker I don't know if we will supposed
to come back and I don't know if we'll
get to see Hellcat in a comic book
costume Jessica Jones as a series
doesn't trade on a lot of that classic
comic book II look just because Jessica
Jones herself laughs in the face of that
like when she met iron fist all she did
was make fun of him that was one of the
best parts of defenders is like him
going off on some tangent and her just
rolling her eyes like yeah whatever dude
you're full of [ __ ] but the really funny
thing you may have noticed if you think
this guy looks familiar this is actually
Wildcat from arrow junior Ramirez he's
not playing a comic-book character he's
just called Oscar it looks like he had
swept up and one of the investigations
that she's working on and they have
chemistry so in the way she got really
drunk and started hooking up with Luke
Cage it seems like that will also happen
with this character here because if
you're wondering about the Jessica Jones
Luke Cage relationship the whole thing
with that is that he's with Claire
temple right now and in Luke Cage season
3 maybe they'll get rid of that maybe
they'll turn that into a bigger thing
but they're kind of doing Heroes for
Hire during Luke Cage season 2 and
that's not coming till later in the year
this is premiering Thursday March 8th
which is actually a day earlier than it
normally would usually Netflix series
drop on Fridays but I think the 8th is
like National Woman's Day or something
like that so it just makes sense that
they would bump Jessica Jones by a
single day just to sync it up with that
just for extra fun just to sort of fill
in the gaps in the time line too if
you're wondering what she was doing
between Jessica Jones season 1 defenders
and then what she's been doing since the
end of defenders it's just normal
investigations like at the beginning of
defenders it was implied that she had
slowly started to take cases again she
hadn't quite come back around Malcolm
was still buzzing around her apartment
fixing things then by the end of that
series it seemed like she had come
around and she was finally taking cases
again but
still had all that stuff since killing
kilgrave brewing in her head that she
hasn't dealt with so like you see her
get arrested here she makes reference to
already having killed someone she's
talking about kilgrave when she says
that a lot of you are asking how they're
gonna tie this stuff in with infinity
war because none of the defenders
characters are going to be in either of
the Avengers movies so it's just a big
question as to how they're going to
address that and they really tried to
downplay the Avengers presence in New
York during the defenders series like I
think they even omitted the actual
Avengers tower people were asking
questions about that earlier this year
so for the most part it does seem like
Marvel's television operation has
completely divorced itself from the
movie operation the good thing about
Jessica Jones season two is that all
these things that you're seeing here are
happening way before infinity war starts
so they don't have to worry about it
that much during this it'll be harder to
address when we get to daredevil season
3 at the end of next year but with
exception to offhanded spider-man
references I'm just not expecting a
whole lot of Avenger stuff to be
happening during Jessica Jones season 2
so we can talk about that again we
actually start getting episodes because
there will be a lot of Easter eggs but
not actual Avengers stuff the schedule
right now is that they're doing Heroes
for Hire right after this they're
dropping it they've already shot that
season and then they're currently
shooting daredevil season 3 right now
meaning they'll probably have it ready
to go in air episodes by the end of next
year but if you want to start getting
ready for stuff start reading daredevil
born again because that's the basis for
daredevil season 3 and then obviously we
have all the infinity war in black
panther stuff that'll be coming up
really soon
you'll start seeing a whole bunch of
black panther footage really really soon
in addition to all the Star Wars stuff
that's dropping so just a heads up I'm
supposed to see Star Wars tonight with
all the other critics I'm allowed to
post my non-spoilery review Tuesday
morning so just a heads up for when
that's going to be coming but there'll
be a lot of other Star Wars videos
posting next week too so just leave all
your requests in the comments below and
I'll just announce the giveaway winner
when I post my agents of shield video
later tonight I'll try to slip that out
after I get back from Star Wars click
here to rewatch that spider-man trailer
and click here to rewatch the infinity
war trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight